ينضم الينا عفوا
ننتقل الان الى انطاكيا وعمر الحاج عمر
الحاج
كنا نتابع هذا اليوم كلمه الرئيس
في اردوغان وعلمنا للتوبه حصول حزار
ارتداديه في انطاكيا من اخبار
يعني جمال لا استطيع لا استطيع وصفه ما
حدث وصف هذا الهلع الان هزه ربما مقاربه
للهزات التي وقعت خلال يوم السادس والسابع
من فبراير انقطعت الاضواء هنا فقط اريد ان
اريك انا اماما كنت امام مدينه خيام انشات
جديده ولكن الارض اهتزت هذا الجسر القريب
من هنا سمعنا اصوات لانفجارات وسمعنا
اصوات لانهيار بعض الابنيه في مدينه
انطاكيا استمر الزلزال لاكثر من 20 ثانيه
بشده نحن كنا واقفين على الارض
اهتزت تماما اصوات الصراخ اصوات البناء
الابنيه التي انهارت يبدو ان هناك ان ابني
انهارت بالتاكيد هناك ابنيه قد انهارت في
هذا الاتجاه اصوات صراخ قطعت الكهرباء كما
تشاهدون من خلفي في المدينه وحدات من
الجيش كانت قريبه من هنا سارعت بالتحرك
هناك
من السلطات المحليه بان هناك هزات اخرى
قويه
متوقعه الهزه حسب نظرت بعجاله الى الاخبار